hey everybody welcome to the great big
story YouTube channel I'm Davis I'm
Jillian let's get to the show this is
part 2 of our great big story food
weekend show where we go into all things
food and taste babies and our first
story is going to be in Las Vegas and
we're going to a pizza topping
competition you know pizza toppings a
sport Jordans it is and we're going to
meet the guy who is the world champion
pizza tesslar let's check it out people
may not think pizza topping is a serious
sport it really is it's a lot of hard
work
[Music]
my name is Tony Gemignani and I'm a
12-time world champion I have two
Guinness Book of World Records one for
most consecutive rolls across the
shoulders in 30 seconds was 36 rolls
across the shoulders 36 or 37 now we'll
say 37
so keep the acrobatic our tricks with
pizza dough a lot of people ask me you
know pizza throwing how do you describe
it it's kind of like what a Harlem
Globetrotter does with a basketball but
we do with the pizza you know around the
back across the shoulders through the
leg two at a time on the ground spinning
in your hands the difference between you
know a basketball and a pizza
it misshapes it gets bigger gets softer
it's not like it's juggling balls that
are always the same it's pretty magical
[Music]
so every year in Las Vegas there's Pizza
Expo and that the pizza echo there's a
world Pizza games when you walked it out
stage there's acrobats from all around
the world competing they'll be getting
judged by a panel of three to five
judges and those judges will look for
dexterity creativity difficulty and as
they're judging them they'll look for
drops and they look for a transition
from trick to trick there's about a two
to three minute routine of music they
have to nail it they've been practicing
all year for it there's a trick in the
sport called the Gemignani my last name
it's a trick that I did it's two across
the shoulders and you catch it
nobody loves ether more than me you know
even I have on my chest that's the pizza
for life
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like what I'm learning is that
pizza just tastes better when it's
flying through the air so we're going to
meet two marques who are doing to send
us let's go to Cuba
[Music]
yo quiero una vida en una ventaja peter
savio vega un cliente hot para okay okay
no by example i reevaluate Utley and I
in the center Havana is a pair of
entrepreneurs for taking Peter
delivering new heights
yo so Martha who know la magia air
marcado llama
[Music]
so how I am Ramona's Casa La Jolla Napa
a principal avocado palatial era Los
Copa piccola Pisa caminando Nikolas no
cancel amo mucho y la gente no pueden
real area in Saudi Isaiah taken a cesta
Baja la vie for a Baskin 2010 monster
number one and her husband were granted
a private business life and open up a
pizzeria a few months ago her husband
passed away now her best friend is
helping her keep Kataria alive Heba
seriously Amma Amma Moneda por que usted
tiene la pizza a la manera so yeah II
know Toto Filipinos
since then the pizzeria which operates
our motto number one group has filled
countless stomachs with their secret
recipe primera vez esta en la maza en la
Salsa Y Capital Genesis aesthetic a
bitter loss de sus casas su manera en no
decency say credo
SOT hemos tratado de Mantegna's nam in
ho chi Toa masa de lama said manuel de
la guerra Laquisha in vista Tilly mint
argv la gente de playa san Mysterio
praia anivia a [ __ ]
nafisa a yacht one Boogaloo a la
interested in videos everywhere ever
since mountain number to join Martin
number one in business
to perform the true partnership I don't
like the way I see Cochise coastal I
don't matter Point Marina vocal timbre
Trudeau hasta las cosas de nominee no no
no sotto voce bouquet garni
in a sundress Edina dreaming go Alan for
next story we're going to head to
content to meet some unexpected chefs I
love these guys so much and I can't wait
for us all to go visit their kitchen
together let's check it out
great big story in here mama we made it
everybody say that is better my mom's
how could you do this they think me we
got our grandma's cooking for us
no this is us we did that right yeah
that's young man okay
trap is is take risk and prosper and
that's what we do in the air so let me
describe kitchen 15 shrimps in the bag
our kitchen is a spot where you prepare
products to be distributed under ground
we just use that mentality with food
we're a full-blown canner serves you
also can ordered for delivery during the
week my team consists of myself and
three other guys I call them my brothers
my boy AWOL DJ care and bad news we're a
small team but we get the job done all
the time you know I mean we've always
Crips and bloods I mean that kind of
stuff of course I'll give a recipe and
every other day for nothing I shoot at
it so now the only thing we worry about
is some food burning looks like I'll run
it up that's it
it's talking to my mom like you got to
do something I'm like okay well what can
I do
I seen the Cordon Bleu commercial on TV
I'm like and I look kind of cool I could
probably do something with that I know
like you make good money cooking I'm
motivated started culinary school and
that's where I began to practice my
craft you know he really came in here
one bag is tea light broke will be going
to like we need some money that way we
can sell some food to Instagram I was
like posting my food and people I all
that looks so good it looks great and I
like okay now it's time for me to offer
this food to the street like howdy boy
pushes though you know K it worked the
key to our success we never gave up man
every day that's all I think about it
talking we improve our company how can
we improve our food how can we improve
the taste even though I'm reading the
house trapping I feel like it's a real
restaurant this is not a duck but our
next story is about ducks in South
Africa who work on a vineyard let's go
meet the class quad
[Music]
they're gonna form the farm in South
Africa the official form because are you
stuck
instead of specified us to work in Raya
[Applause]
my name is James I'm at a very fearful
oof
I'm a duck farmer pesticide Asteras for
the environment the Ducks are not
dangerous
they are metro pest controllers on the
farm the styles were rule why stick
health in the dark prevent it from
happening by eating the snow the first
thing I do is I go into the garage and
there is way we breed our ducks after
that I will start feeding the Ducks then
it color - till in front of the main
house we do something like a doctor
right all our ducks is marching in one
straight line then we send them off to
go and work in the rania and they will
do 50 square metres per day there is
1071 tax in the working group allows a
mr. leaf from breeding ducks in those
Ducks are about 300 tax the favorite is
the crested duck is a duck with a type
of a style like a compliment of visit so
I'll I mean yellows
[Music]
the Ducks are so close to me I see me as
my mommy because I take care of them
each day and I communicate with them
there is for me unique the Ducks are not
only first ducks but they are there for
the reason thanks for watching these
four awesome food stories with us don't
forget to click the horse to subscribe
and comment down below you want cookie
I do want cookie yeah I'm hungry thank
you just okay okay